okay we are
live happy
Monday lot of cool stuff to do
today busy
weekend lots of stuff to work
on I did manage to release
something this is now live can't link it
because Twitter but
website you can just play snake in your
browser this is me controlling it now if
I take my hands off the
keyboard the RL agent just takes
over fun Sim to watch runs on a phone
too you can't actually play it on a
phone because I didn't bother adding
swipe gestures uh but you can play it
like this on the
desktop and uh you know it's fun to
watch all these agents just run live in
your browser nothing serers side
whatsoever
here 500 lines of
C
anyways we got tons of stuff to do today
um I guess we should start by checking
out the experiments on
wandb see what what is finished cuz I
kind of just launched a bunch of giant
sweeps and then let him run all weekend
it looks like they're still going though
they're probably close enough to being
done by
now I just really wanted to see what
happens if we run these for a
ridiculously long
time I think these
two so that's fun I ran almost a
thousand
experiments so here's Breakout
score 448 points per
screen and I'm
assuming can you actually do that with
Atari
H that's
interesting I don't know if it's
achievable with the port that we have at
the moment but uh these graphs are
really
cool because I can so this is how hold
on let it load a lot of experiments so
this is how over the course of carbs you
can kind of see that it's gotten better
and better over time like the massive
experiments goes
up but
also you can do relative time
process and this actually shows you the
fastest
time that it takes to get each of these
uh each of these
results so for our best result here of
393 this
takes little under 1 100
seconds
so little under it's a it's like 17
minutes something like
that that's pretty
fast if I actually look at this
run what's it look like still going up
as well could potentially just keep
running it for
longer I'm I'm actually surprised that
it hasn't run anything for uh for longer
cuz it's allowed to run stuff for up to
an
hour how many agent steps is
this this is not even bad at all in
terms of agent steps it's only like 20
million oh I wonder if I capped it by
mistake I should go check on that if I
capped it to like 20
million here let's
see so if I look at here's episode
reward over time right all these
experiments I got to H how do I do this
um yeah cuz it'll only show a
100 so what if we just filter
to oh it's actually
episode return
greater than equal to
300 that not what it is environment
slash oh greater than
equal hey Peter how many steps should an
agent take to learn breakout I feel like
in my clean RL code it takes quite a
while well let's
see I can it doesn't take very long in
wall clock
time uh we just saw that our best one
was only 20 million steps which is like
a tenth of what the very early uh models
were even using so it's very fast let's
take a look from here though so this is
20 minutes
right we'll actually get this result
right now uh I have to edit the graph
though so you can change this to agent
steps
and you can see that the majority of
these uh these runs are in the range of
20 million steps you can see that by 10
million we already have scores above
300 it's actually quite funny because um
the original clean ARL implementation is
like 10 million steps or whatever and it
gets 150 so if we actually go look at
like what 150 score is actually there's
a 150 score like right
here yeah that's like super fast that's
only a few million
frames and then there's like there's
occasionally this weird outlier
experiment that just I don't know does
something
weird so not very long you probably need
good hyper prems
though same hyper prams also work when
you increase or decrease the total time
steps if you turn uh a kneeling learning
rate and kneeling off then yes and I do
have learning rate and kneeling off for
this for precisely that reason because
otherwise it gets annoying to replicate
sometimes but yeah here are all the
results we can see this one here is
where is
it frame skip of four batch size
65,000 BPT Horizon of 16
pretty normal slightly low maybe clip
coefficient normal slightly low
entropy uh low Lambda but makes sense
very very high gamma which is
interesting for
breakout I wouldn't expect that learning
rate's fine really relatively High
gradient Norm is
interesting really tiny mini batch size
that's
crazy and three updat EPO as well that's
very
weird these are some pretty weird
settings not going to
lie pretty
weird apparently they
work we'll have to think about
that for
sure and if I just go to all these runs
right we can see that the most important
parameter is runtime
can you share your hyper parameters so I
can try them
out my
friend all my stuff's public you should
be able to check every single one of
these in the sweep and play around with
them if you
want but yeah I mean we're outperforming
implementations that used to Take 6
hours in less than 5 minutes so that's
pretty
good run time is correlated and then
what about all
these batch
[Music]
size batch size being negatively
correlated is kind of
this is all of them
overlaid you can see it's like this
genetic algorithm type thing almost
where like it it like sweeps over ranges
for specific parameters and like it'll
slowly lock onto the correct one it's
interesting that's a f that is a fine
graph
though how many is this if it's like 10
million
average if we're going to call this 10
million steps